[Music]
this is not the time for weak leadership
the world faces challenges and problems
like never before
our country needs decisive leaders
leaders who can make tough decisions
fiddling around with public spending
costs or nudging taxes up and down isn't
going to keep the people happy they
demand real change groups on every side
of the debate are crying out for tough
passion they demand that we force the
unemployed to work for their benefits
they want punitive taxes on the rich
others demand that we get our
schoolchildren and our news readers to
sing the national anthem they want
soldiers and politicians to swear
religious Oats there are calls to ban
divorce and same-sex marriages some want
us to ban trade unions others want us to
subsidize them one group pressures me to
outlaw private health care and education
others insist that we let our secret
services use torture to fight terrorism
it's even been suggested that we need to
institute secret courts some people
would call these policies extremism
but it's not for me to judge the will of
the people I'm just a politician and
this is democracy
[Music]
you